hi I'm Evan Carmichael your friend and
all things entrepreneurship today I'm
going to be talking about how I use
Evernote to organize my life I've
created a couple of videos and Evernote
and keep getting asked questions so
today I'm specifically going to look at
how I organize my notebooks and the type
of information that I put in here and
hopefully you can learn from the
structure that I use so I'll go through
each one a little bit of detail
the first one is book so here I'm
working on a book and I'm sharing just
dropping in different notes so these are
quotes I'm going to use here are some
ideas that I'm going to use and the what
I love using Evernote for is just
dumping information that I want to have
available to me on any device so if I
updated here I'm on my office computer
right now it'll show up automatically on
my laptop I can pull it up on my phone
and so wherever I am I have instant
access to all of my notes if I'm just
using one computer and I don't need
access anywhere else then then it's fine
just to use a series of notepad files I
guess but I find this super helpful and
it's easy to do a search up here for any
note that I'm looking for just by
keyword and I can find it so I've
created different notebooks based on
different projects that I'm working on
so a book is the main book project I
guess and I'm working on then business
notes are variety of different things
that I keep coming back to that relate
to my business so New York this is an
agency that I'm working with and some
projects working on a radio show webinar
book some when I talk to them on the
phone I usually write down my to do so I
have to go to New York in early June I
have to book a couple times for them and
when they give me notes or things that
need to remember again on various
devices I can pull it up from anywhere
so this is about a radio show that I'm
that I'm going to be hosting and how to
go about doing it
webinar process this is something that
I've started to do and it's how to get
things promoted through Google Plus so
I've started doing it
I found a great article here that helped
kind of set you up and I only did this
once a month and so I found that I was
forgetting what I was doing every month
so I just recorded the process and put
it down here so every time I create a
new webinar can just refer to my list I
know I have to do in Dreamweaver in my
newsletter software on Google+ on
Facebook YouTube my email software again
and on Twitter and there's more ideas
here if I need to so whenever I come
back to this at the end of every month
it's not starting from scratch again
I've made a process of what I have to do
I'll also clip articles that I find
interesting so one of the things I do is
I work with big companies who are trying
to promote to small businesses and there
was a series of articles in The New York
Times that which was showing you know
how big companies can help small
companies and so this is helpful for me
in the sales process when I'm talking to
some of these bigger companies on what
they can do as well so showing some best
practices so anytime I find an article
that I like I can also clip it and save
it to my folder and it's easy to refer
to that and whenever I need to I could
pull it up on my phone if I'm meeting
them on my iPad and quickly show them so
that's my business notes I put the stars
at the tops just so that they'll rank at
the top because I use these sections a
lot and so it's easy to refer and get
quick access to them when I'm meeting
with my team should have something in
here so a decent Gretchen are people on
my team I can click on and see these are
some of the programs we have going on
and whenever we have our meeting I can
click just quickly update what we're
doing this month any to dues that we
have to do and again a little really
great way for me to refer to and if I'm
meeting him am i if I'm talking talking
from my office it's easy if I'm on the
road I could pull it up on my laptop or
if I'm really on the road I can pull it
up on my phone and it's easy to be able
to have our meeting and take notes and
then the the to dues and updates are
automatically on all my devices whenever
I need
I find that really helpful and just a
series of notes and ideas that I have
you know my big ideas list other
business ideas that I'll that I'll add
to as I come up with different things
that I want to do for my business it's a
big brain dump of things that I want to
do as I'm sure we all have as
entrepreneurs personal notes this this
is just a list of things that I want to
do personally your things that I found
interesting that I want to check out
this is the line-dancing night in Oshawa
this is a Chinese song that I was
learning the lyrics from Cineplex I got
a free popcorn and so I saved this in my
Evernote and then I could just quickly
pull this up on my phone when I went to
Cineplex and they could scan that
barcode and I can get my free large
drink and so you know whatever it is
things I don't remember this was a drink
from a TV show that I saw um that I
wanted to try out so just different
things that I wanted to try and remember
and so it just saved it to a personal
folder business receipts this is why I
got started using Evernote and basically
my my year end is in the middle of the
year and so I'll divide up my receipts
I used a program called the scansnap by
Fujitsu like scanning all our receipts
and I'm automatically pulls them up here
and here is a parking ticket that I got
that I paid for and so five dollars so I
can throw away the piece of paper itself
and I have everything done
electronically so I cannot I can always
pull it up whenever I need to and you
can also do full-text searches if you
ever need to so if I pulled in arcane
let's see that it's pulling in this
parking receipt here and there was
another one from earlier on in the year
I guess as well and so if you ever do in
a search you need to find something it's
a lot easier to find it through a search
full text than it is to look through a
shoebox or look through photocopies or
whatever it is
and so I've saved a lot of time on my
life from being able to quickly find
whatever receipt I'm looking for and
also not have stocks of paper
so really gone paperless here I use it
for my agreements too so this is a
non-disclosure agreement that I had one
of my customers sign and again instead
of keeping the full paper copy I can
scan it in and I can have it be pulled
up here whenever I need to and again I
could search if I was looking for him or
any of the the non-disclosures I could
type in on this on this closure see it's
popping up here and a bunch of other
non-disclosure agreements that have been
signed and faxed in so I always record
these things scan them in they're saved
automatically to Evernote and then I can
delete the actual files themselves and
throw them away and if I ever need to
get access just do a quick search I used
to do it for business cards but I don't
really collect business cards anymore
but you can scan in there business cards
see what you know keep their information
if you ever need to find them just put
the person's name and now everything's
kind of online so don't do as much
government documents this was the last
thing that I kept on to before actually
shredding but you can if you need to get
any hard copy of a government document
back so I scanned all my tax returns and
all that stuff in income returns
corporate documents anything needs to be
filed with the government is
automatically saved in here so again I
could do a quick search to find it so
that's all my business stuff and again
it was the main reason why I started but
we've expanded since then family
receipts same kind of thing or I
recorded all the stuff that I spent with
my family all these various receipts and
again if I ever need to find something
so let's go here and let's go look for I
don't know home
though these are all my home depot
receipts so what did I buy here doesn't
say the item anyway if I ever need to
find a receipt I can pull it up here I
could search for easily find it pull it
up on my iPhone or Samsung or whatever
or my iPad they could scan that barcode
and I can get a refund on it without
ever having to keep that receipt anymore
so just get the receipt scan them in
easy to find access to them through here
and you know get rid of the actual
receipt itself so going paperless at
home as well has helped memories this is
something new that I've just started
doing so I don't have a lot of
information in here but the idea is is
trying to turn memories like cards that
you get instead of chucking them if you
ever need them you know we have these
stacks of paper that what do we do with
at least I did boxes full of memories
that sometimes it's nicely had the
original but a lot of times a digital
copy is great you can print it out
whenever you need to so here is an
example I took my son to Seattle to see
a baseball game and it's his first ever
game and they gave us this certificate
and so like is this something he's ever
going to be interested in or not like he
is he was born in 2009 so am I going to
save this for 20 years and give it to
him you know who knows so at least
there's a digital copy here
it's full-color I can print it off for
him if he really likes it and it doesn't
take up any space really beyond just
some space in my computer but I'm not
collecting stock stuff boxes so this is
something I'm slowly working on adding
new memories and creating different
folders for the years you see I don't
have a lot in here so I've done a great
job on it but something that I'm
planning on doing
and again easy to find either by the
year or by doing a search I could type
in Seattle and this would show up
recipes I am NOT a huge cook yeah but I
thought it'd be cool to try out a few
things and so when I'm on a website and
I find something interesting I can
always save it here this is something
that I want to try out it's making your
own protein bars at home and so it's
from this website that I basically just
clipped put it in here and it's no meat
athlete ultimate homemade protein bar
formula and it gives you a formula for
what to do to create your own protein
bars and different options and how to
make it and so one of these days I'm
going to I'm going to try doing this
this one was for a garlic dip so if you
find something interesting I just kind
of clip it here and put it on the recipe
so again I'm not too active on that but
something interesting salsa I'm very
active in the salsa
world and do a lot of dancing and
teaching and DJing one of the things I
do is I teach a class called the stud
class and so you'll see different
folders have taught five different
versions of it already and I like to
keep notes on what I've taught each year
so I don't teach the same thing the next
time around so I'll make notes on what I
taught that class and scan it in and
then again I don't have to save this
file and then I can go to step two the
next year and see you know what songs I
use and what I taught and go through
that every year so make sure that next
next year I don't do the same program so
just a great way to organize your notes
and again all full-text searchable if I
need to do places to check out these are
things that are in the city TOS Toronto
places I want to check out that I find
interesting
I love reading a blog called blog tio it
basically highlights different things
that are happening in the community and
so this is a saltwater pool that opened
up that I want to check out this is a
community center that there's a bunch of
new stores and restaurants that have
opened up out of shipping containers
that looked interesting that I want
check out this is from blog tio as a
restaurant from Tokyo and just some
information I hear this one I've gone to
so our marques winner it was really good
had some really good ramen I'm in Little
Italy part of Toronto here and so again
I'll just clip it from the web as a
reminder and if I don't know so I don't
know about you guys what sign says
sometimes I find myself thinking what
should I do this weekend or what should
I do tonight and you're kind of at a
little loss for things to potentially do
so I'll look at my Evernote folder and
see what I've saved and so maybe I'll go
check out this community center with all
the stores in the shipping containers or
I'll check out this other new restaurant
or go for a saltwater pool swim and I
can either save it with a winner or I'll
delete it if I don't like it and so
again something I find helpful and again
it's all available on your phone and if
you're trying to find the place you know
usual I'll write down the address and
put a map in here as well so I can
quickly pull it up on my phone when I'm
close an indication I've used it a lot
for as well let's pull up one trip here
so this was a cruise that I did and what
I did was for every city so this is a
Ensenada I would go to I think it's a
strip advisor and pull in some of the
things that I liked from here and give
it as an option and so put pictures and
what it's all about and usually they
give you some kind of map there so I'll
just have to go find where these places
are and to find this super helpful again
because I can pull it up on my phone and
I'm walking around and when we're you
know thinking about what to do next I've
already done all the research and pull
it up we talked about it over dinner I
could share my hotel information so
again I could pull it up anywhere so we
sit at the Renaissance in Long Beach
shuttle information how to get to and
forth
this was a best buy so we bought a GPS
we wanted to buy a GPS system and so I
pulled it up at the hotel on my computer
did a quick google map of how to find
the place because we didn't have a GPS
and I popped it into into my iPad I
popped it into Evernote then I could
pull it up on my iPad and quickly find
out how to get to the closest Best Buy
so we had a GPS so lots of different
ways to use it I've kind of classified
it by you know priority projects things
I'm interested in things that refer to
an ongoing basis with the three star so
they show up at the top my book is my
project that business notes personal
notes and the things that I use ongoing
my business receipts family receipts
memories I'm trying to save recipes I'm
interested in my teaching my dancing
places the check out in Toronto and when
I go on vacation and so I found it
really helpful I keep finding new ways
to use Evernote and really I just think
of it as a as a place to dump stuff and
keep a running tab on different projects
that I'm working on and then quickly be
able to access it from any location that
I'm at and that's really one of the big
things that makes a difference for me if
I find that I'm going to need to access
this file from multiple locations and
especially when I'm mobile that I'm I'm
popping into Evernote because it's the
fastest way to get access to that
information so hopefully that helped
with all you guys are having questions
about how to organize your Evernote it's
definitely not the only way to do it I'm
sure there's a lot of other fun creative
ways to use it and again I'm always
finding different options for it too but
if you guys like this video you want to
see more similar ones please give it a
like below a thumbs up I love seeing
those come in and if you have a specific
question about Evernote how I use it
I'm happy to do another video and kind
of drill down a little deeper so feel
free to leave those in the comments
section below I always read those and
even if you just like the video leave a
comment too it really makes my day seen
those come in so thank you guys and I'll
see you on the next episode
you